hey 42 here currently there are 118
elements that we have discovered and
logged on the periodic table elements
are strange things simply adding or
removing a single proton from the atom's
nucleus of an element completely changes
it and essentially makes it a new
element here's the weirdest elements
from the periodic table that seemed to
defy the laws of physics first up is
gallium a soft metal that's sometimes
used in electronics but it has a unique
party trick it safely melts in human
hands then re solidifies again once it
dropped below its 30 degrees Celsius
melting point in the early 20th century
a popular prank amongst chemists at
university what to smelt gallium in two
utensils than what as their classmates
knife and fork melted away from their
hands as they ate what if you think of
metal becoming a liquid at room
temperature is weird how about a metal
being a gaps at room temperature
copernicium
is a highly radioactive synthetic metal
it is one of the weirdest and most
elusive elements because of two reasons
firstly it decays extremely fast it has
an astonishingly short half-life of just
29 seconds so it doesn't stick around
for very long and secondly it is a gas
at room temperature both these factors
make it extremely difficult for
scientists to study subsequently we
still don't know very much about this
elusive substance curium is an extremely
radioactive substance that was named
after Marie Curie only a few kilograms
of curium are produced each year because
it doesn't have very many use
however if what's used on a Mars mission
in an alpha proton x-ray spectrometer
but what makes this element so unique is
that it's so radioactive that it
actually glows in the dark
next up is francium a naturally
occurring element named after France
francium is one of the alkali metals all
of which are extremely volatile but
francium is the most reactive of all the
alkali metals at its most stable isotope
it has a very short half-life of just 22
minutes and is unbelievably rare it
usually pops into existence one atom at
a time then disappears almost
instantaneously it is estimated that
there are only about 20 grams of
francium on the planet at any one time
scientists aren't even able to procure a
sample of francium large enough so that
it's visible to the naked eye therefore
studying it is almost impossible but we
do know that when put into water the
reaction will be spectacularly dangerous
considering that the next most reactive
alkali metal is cesium
which explodes when it touches water
however francium is considerably more
volatile than cesium uncursed the
moisture in the air alone would cause
francium to explode spectacularly next
up is a group of eight different
elements all relatively new to the
periodic table they are all man-made
they all have similar names and were all
discovered in the exact same manner by
scientists from barding atoms at one
element with atoms of another element
this separates them into completely new
elements but only for a fraction of a
second the first to be discovered alum
vien was first created in 1996 in a lab
in Germany
none of these elements have been seen
for more than a second under their
inclusion on the periodic table still
remains under investigation bismuth is
the heaviest non radioactive metal
actually it's very very very slightly
radioactive but it has a half-life
billions of times longer than the
current age of the universe so for
argument's sake it's fair to say that
it's completely stable bismuth is used
in medicine and cosmetics but it has a
unique attribute it is diamagnetic which
means it emits a magnetic field in the
opposite direction to any externally
applied magnetic field in layman's terms
if you put a magnet between two lumps of
bismuth it will levitate indefinitely
you probably imagine sulfur as a yellow
rock but it can actually change to an
array of different colors under
different conditions one of the weirdest
such examples can be seen if you melt
sulfur it turns from a solid yellow rock
to a blood-red liquid also just as cool
if you burn sulfur it produces a neon
blue flame but sulfur has a disgusting
side too it's responsible for the odor
of rotten eggs garlic onions and many
other nasty smells in fact most things
that smell bad have some sulfur in Neffs
somewhere next up is helium
it's a colorless odorless tasteless
inert gas which means it doesn't react
with other elements it's boiling and
melting points are the lowest of any
element at an unimaginably low minus 272
point two degrees Celsius helium turns
into a superfluid which exhibits a
unique property if you pour helium in
its superfluid form into a vessel it
seems to defy gravity and creep off the
walls of the container and pour over the
rim to try and reach a warmer place
where it will avail
actually evaporate but by far the thing
that makes helium so damn extraordinary
is this if it wasn't for this next
element you wouldn't be watching this
video right now I am of course talking
about silicon a crucial component in all
computer chips and most electronics it's
even got an entire Valley named after it
in California it's also responsible for
silky white beaches being the most
common component in sand oh and don't
forget breast implants too is one of the
most common elements on earth about 27%
of the Earth's crust is made up of
silicon silicon is a remarkable element
because it's largely responsible for the
technological revolution of the past 30
years and finally it may not be
particularly strange but it is arguably
the most amazing element the elements
I'm talking about is carbon it is the
most essential element to support life
it is the building block of everything
living DNA proteins cells coal pencils
diamonds the air you breathe in the food
you eat are all made up from carbon as
well as countless other things carbon
compromises 20% of the weight of all
living organisms to put it simply if it
wasn't for carbon we wouldn't be here
and neither would the universe as we
know it so for that reason alone it
deserves some attention thanks for the
view subscribe for more thoughty2